Un spécialiste du décryptage des grandes surfaces.
Ce professeur très réputé a étudié dans les moindres détails
la stratégie de vente d'Ingvar Kamprad
en passant des jours à observer ses plans .
- Ceci est le plan d'un magasin I KEA au nord de Londres.
Au départ, voilà ce qui l'a intrigué.
En tant qu'architecte,
il trouvait leurs plans particulièrement compliqués.
- La 1re fois que j'ai mis les pieds dans un magasin IKEA,
j'étais complètement perdu, un peu déboussolé
car je n'arrivais pas à comprendre
comment il était possible de faire du shopping en étant totalement désorienté.
Et le professeur a constaté que dans ce labyrinthe,
les clients empruntaient pourtant tous exactement le même chemin ,
indiqué par IKEA.
Et selon lui, c'est pour leur faire acheter plus d'articles.
- Vous venez en ayant une idée précise de ce que vous voulez acheter,
mais comme vous ne pouvez pas trouver tout de suite votre article
parce que vous êtes perdu, eh bien, vous passez devant plein de choses
dont vous n'auriez pas imaginé avoir besoin.
Et lorsque vous les voyez, vous vous dites :
"Oh, j'aimerais bien en avoir un !"
Alors vous le mettez dans votre sac.
Un parcours imposé, une idée que Kamprad a copié e à New York
en visitant ce musée d'art contemporain, le musée Guggenheim,
à l'architecture spectaculaire.
Le bâtiment est entièrement circulaire ,
et ceci pour guider les visiteurs à travers un parcours unique
qui leur permet de voir l'ensemble des chefs-d'oeuvre sans en rater un seul.
En reprenant l'idée du parcours imposé,
Kamprad va faire exploser ses ventes.
Dans son étude publiée en 2011,
Alan Penn estime que 67 % des produits que vous achetez dans ces magasins
le sont de manière compulsive,
c'est-à-dire qu'il s n'étaient pas prévu s sur votre liste.
Mais alors comment IKEA s'y prend-elle pour nous
mener ainsi par le bout du nez ?
- Allons chez IKEA faire le parcours et voir ce que cela donne.
Et nous voilà partis avec Alan Penn pour une démonstration
après laquelle vous ne verrez plus votre grande surface de la même manière.
- Prenez le rond-point .
L'entrée est ici.
Il faut dire que sa thèse est au point.
C'est en se rendant des dizaines de fois dans ce magasin de Londres
qu'il a pu la tester.
Nous le suivons en caméra discrète.
Selon le professeur, toute la stratégie du géant suédois
repose sur ce système de flèches au sol.
Si elles n'existaient pas, nous serions totalement perdus
par le plan volontairement compliqué du magasin.
- Pourriez-vous me dire dans quelle direction est l'entrée,
où est garée la voiture ?
C'est dans quelle direction ?
Pointez du doigt .
- Aucune idée.
- Vous n'en savez rien parce qu'on tourne en rond.
Selon le professeur, pour pouvoir mieux guider les clients à sa guis e,
dans un 1er temps, le magasin les désoriente.
- L'entrée du magasin, si je veux la rejoindre ?
C'est par où, à votre avis ?
- Euh... L'entrée du magasin ?
Ouh là là, j'en sais strictement rien.
Peut-être là-bas.
Impossible de se diriger par soi-même.
Il faut faire confiance aux flèches.
Pourtant, il existe bien des raccourcis,
mais ils sont beaucoup moins bien indiqués,
et le plus souvent, on les passe s ans les voir.
- Le parcours , là, est évident.
Vous allez par ici et vous continuez à suivre les flèches.
Mais en fait, sans le savoir, vous venez de passer un raccourci.
Venez, je vais vous montrer.
Effectivement, nous étions passés sans le voir
à côté de ce petit couloir , et ce n'est pas par hasard.
- Il n'y a aucune pancarte qui vous l'indique.
Le chemin, lui , est très clair.
Donc on passe par là, et lorsque vous êtes ici,
vous l'avez déjà dans le dos.
Vous ne le voyez jamais.
Si vous le savez, vous évitez toute une boucle.
Des raccourcis qui sont en fait destinés
aux vrais initiés du magasin, les vendeurs,
pour qu'ils ne perdent pas trop de temps dans leur s déambulations.
Et ce n'est pas tout.
Selon le professeur, tout est fait aussi pour qu'on perde la notion du temps.
Les rayons sont aveugles, ils n'ont pas de fenêtres.
- C'est comme dans un casino, c'est comme à Las Vegas.
- Qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire par là ?
- Vous n'avez aucune idée si c'est le jour ou la nuit.
Vous ne pouvez pas voir l'extérieur, et ça, ça vous désoriente totalement.
On ne s'occupe plus du temps et on se laisse guider par les flèches.
Le magasin peut concentrer toute notre attention
sur ce qu'il veut qu'on achète.
Des accessoires à petit prix
sur lesquels on bute en permanence dans les allées,
et qu'en général, on n'avait pas prévu d'acheter.
- Là, vous avez 4 cintres pour 1,30 euro.
Ca coûte quelques centimes à fabriquer.
Ca vient peut-être de Chine.
C'est sans doute une marge à 1 000 %.
On vient ici pour les prix imbattables sur le mobilier,
et après, on se fait plaisir sur les autres offres.
Ca nous coûte presque rien.
Je dépense 100 euros sur un lit,
et là, c'est seulement 1,30 euro.
D'accord. J'en prends 4, alors !
Voilà comment, selon le professeur, le géant suédois
parviendrait à nous faire quitter ses magasins
avec 2 tiers d'articles en plus que prévu.
Et ainsi, année après année, la marque ne cesse de développer ses magasins.